étranger merci de rien vous
êtes une source d'inspiration monsieur vous êtes
Smith, d'accord, euh, eh
bien, j'ai une arthrite dégénérative
et une
scoliose de Kaifos qui est plus bas sur
le côté gauche de mon dos et ça
me tord sur le côté comme ça
alors et  ça ne va pas s'améliorer
et j'ai la même chose
dans les mains
et les pieds
donc ça n'aide pas mais je ne me plains pas
et ne me plains pas parce que c'est la vie
mais je pense que j'use mes jambes
euh quoi  une sorte de personne, je
me décrirais comme étant juste
une personne normale qui aime sortir
et
déteste rester assise à ne rien faire,
juste une personne normale désolé,
la principale chose que je ne veux pas faire est d'
arrêter,
j'espère pouvoir  faire tout le
Camino
mais je doute que
tu n'obtiennes pas mon lait
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique]
te donne ce genre de Conscience ou d'
attention et je pense que cela nous conduit à l'
introspection
[Musique]
la marche elle-même non  ce n'est pas facile la
distance et puis aussi monter et descendre
le temps donc il y a vraiment ce
sentiment de souffrance mais je pense qu'il y a
vraiment quelque chose dans l'esprit humain
qui est capable d'aller au-delà de la douleur physique, ils
recherchent quelque chose dans leur
la vie est une sorte de carrefour, d'autres viennent
ici à cause d'une crise particulière qui
s'est produite et qu'ils doivent accepter.
Je crois que l'expérience
du Chemin nous donne la force d'aller
à l'étranger.
[Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
Église fantastique pour retrouver le père
tenant le soleil
en novembre de
l'année dernière. J'ai perdu mon mari Paul,
il a succombé à un cancer,
le diagnostic a duré trois ans et a
survécu à toutes les prédictions en termes de
type de cancer qui était du pancréas, euh,
mais est décédé le 23 novembre.  l'
année dernière, c'était à deux mois de
notre 30e anniversaire de mariage,
euh,
c'était
un peu un coup dur pour
moi, tu sais, j'ai passé ma 50e année à
penser assez jeune à être veuve,
vraiment.
Tout change du jour au lendemain et
tu sais que tu es juste pour toujours
anticiper
la fin,
marcher pour le chagrin, je suppose que
marcher pour
laisser un peu de temps pour traiter ce qui
s'est passé, penser à
mon mari Paul et
travailler à une conclusion et m'asseoir
libre pour boxer en avant,
vous savez que vous marchez, disons
sans doute 25 000 par jour, vous devenez jolie  près
de ça, ce
que vous pensez sera de 25 000 au cours de
ces trois ou quatre derniers, vous êtes
prêt à finir,
les corps crient,
mais j'ai trouvé un moyen vraiment intéressant, vous
savez, d'
entrer dans le logement, d'enlever votre
sac à dos et de
prendre un verre et une douche.  et puis
tu te sens toujours bien, ce qui me
fait vivre en ce moment,
c'est en fait de trouver toutes ces nouvelles
relations
tu avais tout l'argent du monde
que ferais-tu où irais-tu comment
cela affecterait-il ta vie j'inventerais
une pilule qui changerait le temps  Je revenais avec un tout
nouveau contexte qui fonctionnerait tout le
temps ouais
et ça resterait droit. Je donnerais
tout à chaque centre de recherche
qui
essayait de trouver des remèdes contre le vaisseau.
Quand je revenais du premier Camino, j'ai
dit aux gens que c'était
ça a
changé ma vie et, en quelque sorte, en amenant
mon gendre,
sa fille est morte de la mucoviscidose à
l'âge de 17 ans.
Maddie était simplement aimée de tout le monde.  Je
veux dire qu'elle voulait vivre pleinement sa vie,
elle vient juste de sortir et l'a fait, elle
n'a jamais laissé sa maladie l'empêcher
de faire quoi que ce soit. Je
ne vais pas dire que je crois ou
quoi que ce soit, mais je veux dire, je viens probablement ici pour en
chercher.  des réponses sur la raison pour laquelle elle
a été emmenée
ouais [ __ ] tu m'as forcé à le faire
J'ai plaisanté avec Maddie sur le fait qu'elle pouvait venir
mais elle avait la mucoviscidose,
elle n'aurait jamais pu faire ça et nous avons donc
décidé de le faire pour elle, c'est très
spécial  chose pour nous
[Musique]
il y a un énorme esprit de camaraderie sur
le Camino
même si tu t'arrêtes sur le côté pendant cinq
minutes les gens vont inévitablement te croiser
et te dire tu vas bien as-tu besoin de
quelque chose puis-je te donner peux je te donner
des médicaments peux  Je fais ceci, je peux faire
cela
[Musique]
J'ai ordonné d'entendre pardon J'ai ordonné pour
toi
parce que c'est tu dois sauter un nouveau
petit
donc je te préfère je
le tiens je
je vais bien
[Rires]
le mal m'a tiré dehors
trop lourd mon sac est trop lourd
tu sais ce que tu vas devoir faire
flotter tu vas devoir arrêter de penser aux
personnes âgées nous ne sommes pas des personnes âgées Nous sommes jeunes
en passant un peu d'énergie
ok
c'est ok tu te sens mieux maintenant
quand tu  j'en ai besoin d'un autre tu sais où
aller j'ai froid nous n'y arriverons jamais
nous continuons à nous arrêter il y
a cette belle
importation de gens et d'amitié et de
camaraderie comment vas-tu Julie
alors la salle de douche est toute bloquée et a
inondé
les pros et  les inconvénients évidemment de se retrouver
avec un groupe de personnes que
vous n'avez jamais rencontré dans votre vie avant de
vous lancer dans une aventure comme celle-ci
se réveiller dans un dortoir avec tout le bruit
ne pas avoir assez dormi
ce n'est pas une bonne chose mais la beauté  d'
être dans un groupe parce que nous prenons tous
soin les uns des autres bonjour à Rachel salut
Rachel bonjour
elle est juste rockée je pense que les kiwis ont
ça tu sais une façon unique de se comprendre
quel était l'anniversaire de Madison
ah le 15 juin vous obtenez tout  les meilleurs
voeux des biscuits et du papier toilette Je
n'arrive pas à croire combien de papier toilette nous
avions un peu simple, ils sont
juste faciles
Je sais que beaucoup de gens font le Camino
seuls mais je pense que pour moi
cela aurait été tout simplement trop  dur euh
ce qui s'est passé tu sais tu rencontres des gens
et tu parles avec eux et tu te
souviens d'il y a quelques jours et tu
rencontres cette dame
juste pour quelques minutes seulement
et un de mes meilleurs amis vit
en dehors de l'Arizona,
nous parlions de le faire  ensemble
mais elle travaille toujours à merveille
ouais
c'est
agréable de le faire soi-même
avant de venir en Europe as-tu un peu remis en question
ta vie
et oui oui
[Musique]
je pense que c'est la voie à suivre,
je n'ai pas besoin de l'admettre à nouveau maintenant
alors  ce matin je marche la plupart du temps seul
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
merci au revoir
23 24 surtout 24 km demain ouais à quoi
ressemble le terrain euh
il fait
un peu de haut en bas
on a des hauts et des bas tout le temps et
tu sais à quel point c'est dur  pour monter
et un pas à la fois vous atteignez le sommet
et le paysage est si beau et vous
descendez espérons que
vous devrez recommencer
ouais c'est la vie le Camino c'est la vie
quand la douleur arrive vraiment fort je
veux juste m'asseoir  là et va baiser, ils
s'enflamment beaucoup
ça fait vraiment mal donc je pleure pas mal
tout seul l'après-midi
ok
alors marchons
[Musique]
tu connais l'histoire du petit moteur rouge
je pense que je  je peux penser que je peux je pense que je
peux
ok je sais je peux je sais je peux je
le sais au revoir
[Musique]
d'accord je
ne peux pas le faire
[Musique]
comment te sens-tu de devoir prendre le bus, ça
ne marche pas  ne m'inquiète pas
[Musique]
merci
étrangère [Musique
]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
pâtes
[Musique]
où vas-tu je ne sais pas
étrangère
[Musique]
tu te souviens j'ai partagé avec toi le  histoire
de San Domigo de la causa où
ces parents ont perdu leur fils
pour moi, cela a un double sens, le
premier est quand vous perdez un enfant, ce
qu'aucun parent ne veut savoir,
mais le second est que l'enfant
vous le dise  Maman Papa je suis là avec toi je suis toujours
en vie
ok
alors je te souhaite une bonne paix
à partir de maintenant essaye de lâcher prise
si quelqu'un d'autre veut du chocolat blanc
parfois je ne me souviens pas de ce que je dis aux
gens mais à travers ma parole ils  touché
et euh c'est
ça la beauté,
vous ne savez pas avec qui vous marchez,
si vous marchez avec la personne la plus pauvre
de la Terre ou la personne la plus riche de
la Terre, mais par inadvertance, vous en apprenez davantage
sur les autres à chaque étape du processus.
et puis j'ai embrassé un Espagnol
[Applaudissements]
Je suis un Vénézuélien oui
wow
alors je lui ai donné un cow-boy à chaque fois que tu les vois,
tu grandis un peu plus avec
ces gens, quel genre de musique aimes-tu
aussi toutes sortes sauf  pour le
jazz moderne ouais mais combien d'années as-
tu passé ensemble avec oh deux
deux ouais trop longtemps ah Terry
[Rires]
depuis 1972. et bien devinez à quelle date
je me suis marié
le 2 décembre
1972. ok
le lendemain de l'anniversaire de Damien nous étions
ensemble
31 ans avant notre séparation et je pense que
nous devons traverser, est-ce que nous devons traverser la
passerelle
ouais c'est oh, n'est-ce pas, non, on y va,
on y va, tu ferais mieux d'y aller en premier,
je me retrouve à appeler Kathy deux fois par
jour.  ça fait une énorme différence, n'est-ce pas ?
J'ai appelé Damien sur Messenger et
il a dit très fier de toi, tellement fier de
toi, il y avait un peu de décalage entre
ce qu'on disait et mais une fois qu'on s'y
est habitué, c'était  vraiment, vraiment
merveilleux,
je suis plutôt,
généralement plutôt hippie, une
personne adorable, nous sommes tous des gens très différents,
pas nécessairement des gens que vous
recherchez et la vie normale en soi a
probablement passé plus de temps avec de l'art
Terry et Cheryl,
j'ai l'impression que nous sommes vraiment  en fait,
j'avais 23 ans quand nous nous sommes mariés. Stéphanie
n'avait pas parlé de fonder une famille et
c'est un peu un choc pour le système. Nous sommes
allés en Europe et nous étions en Grèce
quand j'ai perdu les eaux. Sam, enceinte d'environ 32
semaines, nous sommes de retour.  assez
nerveusement mais heureusement, c'était un bel
été parmi ceux qui ont réussi à
concevoir le numéro deux, leur
as-tu parlé ce matin juste
Christy ouais ok comment va-t-elle bien ouais
tu me manques ça a l'air un peu plat alors nous
ici ouais non non non où sommes-nous peut-être que nous  Je
suis en forme là-bas avec Grant, il me manque
énormément mais
je les applique en Europe en juillet
pour son anniversaire, il me ressemble beaucoup,
il a aussi cette envie de merveilles,
je sais que ça va, je suis en Espagne, j'ai l'air
beaucoup mieux, donc je suis  j'ai hâte,
je sais que nous sommes dans le café néo-zélandais,
je sais que nous allons
bien, je veux voir le monde entier,
tu sais et je ne suis pas un poulet de printemps, donc
et il y a beaucoup de choses que je veux
rayer de ma liste de choses à faire.
Je suis assez ouvert à tout, tu sais, je
n'ai pas toutes ces idées préconçues
sur ce que je vais retirer du
Camino, je suis juste le courant
tous les jours,
tu sais que la vie est si courte si tu te
sens heureux.  et content et laisse les
bons moments rouler
Je ne bois pas ça maintenant c'est fou
[Musique]
Je rencontre des gens en cours de route, ils
pourraient être sur le Camino et ils
logeaient dans des hôtels
Je ne peux pas non plus vivre en dortoir donc je'  Je viens
juste de me battre, j'ai découvert que j'avais de
gros insectes, ils me rendent fou,
tellement garce,
cette équipe vient avec la piqûre de moustique,
c'est un endroit effrayant
oh, je viens de partir,
je ne sais pas comment entrer,
comment vais-je  je vais l'avoir, ils ne m'ont pas donné
de code
[Musique]
c'est un peu étrange, c'est
bien d'avoir cet hôtel comme pause
et de se ressourcer et sortir ce soir
sera juste une bonne façon de se
déstresser en regardant vite et comme l'espagnol  des
robes résistantes quelque chose que vous savez
qu'elles empilent sur l'épaule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
Je m'embrasse ensemble [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
le Camino est composé de trois étapes,
le premier tiers est l'étape physique
et ensuite vous leur offrez un Setter où vous
continuez à marcher péniblement et péniblement
[Musique]
J'ai entendu des histoires de gens disant oh je  Je vais
prendre le bus et les contourner Etc parce que
c'est tellement ennuyeux, ce n'est pas le problème, c'est le
mental, la machette est le
stade mental, il faut garder la
tête baissée et il faut continuer
[Musique]
si c'était le cas'  t pour Black Sabbath,
je n'y serais jamais arrivé
Je suis très sérieux,
où trouves-tu les Bears
[Musique]
c'est dimanche,
euh, nous y sommes, je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils le dirigent tous, tous les noms se rencontrent dans
chacun  autre
donc tu es un peu fatigué et épuisé, comment tu te
sens ce matin quand tu te réveilles,
ça fait du bien quand je me suis réveillé
et je voulais vraiment y aller
quand je me suis réveillé
et maintenant je me sens un peu grincheux
[Musique  ]
J'adorerais faire ça avec
Diamond
à cause de la situation, je ne peux pas, il
adorerait le faire avec moi aussi mais
il est avec son partenaire,
lui et moi sommes de bons amis ouais ouais
nous étions ensemble
depuis 32 ans.
[Musique]
quand tu marches jours après jours après jours
après jours sans rencontrer personne qui te perde
et que tu apprends à avoir confiance que tout ira bien
à la fin de la journée, c'est comme avoir confiance en
ta vie
[Musique]
donc c'est
un soulagement que  J'ai découvert la
situation malheureuse dans laquelle je me trouve à
ce moment-là, tout seul.
Je parlerais de tout ça avec Paul de ce que je
ferais à l'avenir et j'apaise son
esprit en lui disant que je n'en avais pas besoin.
je m'inquiète du fait que
tout irait bien
[Musique]
c'était en quelque sorte une sorte de simple
gestion du quotidien,
euh,
vous connaissez la routine, il
suffit de mettre un pied devant l'
autre et de s'en sortir, mais  euh
les locaux sont sympathiques le village est
incroyable tu sais
merci
ouais ouais au revoir
derrière mes jambes j'avais l'air et je me sentais comme
une personne ivre qui marchait
et
les gens marchaient derrière moi en disant si
tu vas bien en as-tu eu
quelques-uns hier soir je n'en avais pas,
je l'ai dit  tu parles de mon rhume des
14 derniers jours
ouais et
bien j'ai l'intention de m'en débarrasser
[Musique]
je vais
bien mourir j'ai vu quelqu'un revenir dans ton
corps tu sembles être capable d'arriver là où
tu es  je dois y aller, qu'il reste 10 km à
parcourir ou 1 km à parcourir,
nous sommes à qu'est-
ce que j'ai dit que c'était avant le
centre géographique du Camino donc
c'est la prochaine étoile apparemment comme ce
gâteau Facile
ouais ouais c'est tout en descente à partir d'
ici
les gens  dis oh je ne pouvais pas aller plus loin
oui tu peux
j'ai une genouillère en ce moment
et la dernière fois c'était une cheville roulée
tout le monde a déjà mal tu vas
plus vite que moi
hein allez prends-le pour le
lien d'équipe  à partir de cette foulée,
mon dos devient de plus en plus douloureux et je
veux pouvoir continuer à marcher
mais je dois parfois m'arrêter
et aller m'allonger et
je ne peux rien y faire
[Musique]
juste sur la piste
Honnêtement, c'était juste devant
mes pieds,
je ne peux pas le laisser ici,
je ne pouvais pas y croire,
ce que nous avons appris sur le deuil par rapport aux aspects
académiques et professionnels et
tout ce que
vous recherchez pour avoir un sens, vous vous
le donnez
quand vous êtes en confiance.
[Musique  ] le
deuxième jour, quand nous gravissions cette
colline dans la boue tout
seul pendant quelques heures,
sans personne et juste montée après
montée après montée
ouais tu es parti comme une gazelle
j'ai vu un panneau qui disait rouler 50 mètres
devant mais là  c'était une montée comme je le jure,
il y avait un angle proche de 90 degrés pour
arriver à la route et puis, sorti de nulle part,
ce chien est apparu ouais, le vieux chien sauvage
au milieu de nulle part, je ne sais pas
d'où il venait,
je savais que je  Je ne pouvais pas m'en sortir, c'était tout
simplement trop et je ne pouvais pas le faire
et de nulle part, ce chien est arrivé
et le chien n'arrêtait pas de m'entourer, vous
savez, et je n'irais nulle part où je ne
voulais pas aller.  parce que je ne voulais pas monter,
je voulais faire demi-tour et revenir en arrière,
je ne voulais plus le faire
et le chien tournait autour de moi,
puis montait quelques marches en haut de la colline, arrêtez-vous, retournez-vous
vers moi
et je  Je lui parle et je dis
qu'est-ce que tu veux de moi
et il reviendrait vers moi, ferait le
tour de moi, puis remonterait la colline
et je me dis,
c'est que toi, Millie,
c'était vraiment dur mais ça  mon chien m'a fait
gravir cette colline
et aussi vite qu'il m'a fait gravir cette colline,
il a de nouveau disparu, il avait disparu donc
si Maddie n'a pas envoyé ce chien en bas, je
ne sais pas si
quelqu'un l'a fait
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
étranger
[Musique]
découvre quels quatre pouvons-nous avoir quatre
shots ouais
[Musique]
J'étais ici, je ne le sais que le
29 novembre, donc nous nous en occupons
après cela et nous nous occupons
des conséquences de la mort  comme vous le faites
et le jeudi de la
semaine suivante, quand mon fils m'a dit qu'il était en train de parler de
ce voyage, il allait
partir
lundi
et ce samedi matin, c'était une
belle matinée et j'ai aussi fait du
paddle board pendant quelques heures.  heures
et je suis allé au cinéma ce soir-là avec
la petite amie et à 10 h 30 j'ai allumé mon téléphone
et il y avait un message de mon voisin
et pouvez-vous m'appeler qui semblait
vraiment impressionné, j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment étrange
et j'ai dit
écoute, je suis  Je n'essaie pas de dire ça, mais
la police est là pour te chercher,
mon amie Michelle Greg, m'a enlevé les clés de la voiture
et elle est
rentrée chez elle en voiture, ce qui est à environ 20 ou 25 minutes
de route et j'étais apparemment juste assis
à côté d'un visage blanc et le corps à corps était le
tout le chemin et elle essayait de me parler,
euh,
ils avaient un ami qui est un
policier local qui était venu
prendre la relève des deux jeunes Cox,
ce ne serait rien pour moi donc il savait que
Sam Craig savait que quelqu'un
m'avait fait asseoir  ensuite,
j'ai juste dit qu'il y avait eu
un accident sur la rivière,
euh,
le radeau avait descendu la rivière
et s'était renversé et ils ne pouvaient pas
l'écrire
et
ils auront la chance de le mettre en
sécurité
[Musique]
toujours reconnaissant
vous'  c'est vrai ouais, ils sont plus brillants,
tu es un très bon chanteur, j'en
ai un autre pour toi en français, il y a
un moment que je pense que
nous pourrions
[Musique]
un autre enterrement, la tentation n'était
pas de le faire, mais ensuite, vous
savez, nous avons parlé, Aaron a
décidé  que Sam devait aussi être
expulsé d'une manière ou d'une autre a réussi à passer Noël
et nous nous
dirigeons tous lentement vers la famille profondément
changée
qui est passée de cinq à
trois ans. Je suis allé à Santiago l'année dernière,
puis je vais à Rum, ça fait le  le chemin avec
moi vers Santiago est faux c'est beaucoup d'
énergie c'est de l'
énergie pour toi tu vois
oh merci beaucoup
je connais ta douleur
[Musique]
ok
wow [
Musique]
[Musique]
rit
ce qui se passe
prends en compte
USA
se lève le matin mais  J'en arriverai
probablement au point où je n'aurai plus
envie de marcher pendant quelques jours
et ça m'énerve vraiment,
c'est vraiment le cas
quand
ouais j'espère donc
j'essaierai à nouveau demain quand nous nous
lèverons  pour voir ce que demain m'apportera
ouais
ça paye pour te regarder souffrir
juste ma personnalité têtue et têtue je
suppose que
allons-y
[Musique]
ce que j'aime
dans le Camino est tellement libérateur parce que
dans le monde parfois on se demande ce que
celui-ci va penser si  tu dis que
ceci ou celui-ci va l'emmener
là-bas, je m'en fiche,
je dis juste quelle est ta note oh
tout dépend de quelle façon tu le regardes,
j'étais content avec mes enfants et
tout mais bientôt la porte s'est fermée,
c'est tout toi  retrouvez-vous seul
ouais vous vous retrouvez seul en Europe
où que vous viviez ouais donc vous devez
vraiment lâcher prise
ouais les gens se comportent envers vous de toutes
sortes de manières différentes je ne sais pas euh
arrête juste au moins et aide allez
allez Julie sois  courageux
[Musique]
je vais bien il y a quelques choses écrites
et rouges
je l'ai vu
quitter ton chagrin quitter ton âme flèche
accord
adorable adorable
tout le monde pense différemment voir les choses
différemment
cela ne m'affecte pas du tout
je n'ai jamais été du genre à  on me dit
quoi faire, je suis un monde assez fort et
nous sommes tous là pour notre propre communauté
[Musique]
est-ce le vrai Camino non, ce n'est pas le cas, je suis
désolé oh oui, ça a l'air amusant mais toi, qu'est-ce que
tu apprendras rien  il s'agit de
marcher dans la nature en écoutant le bruit
des oiseaux que le ruisseau
observe tranquillement en direct, des
étrangers
très inquiets pour la sécurité des
membres restants de la famille, y compris
moi-même, vous savez,
donc je me sentais vraiment mal
d'être ici,
sachant qu'elle est là, juste en train de lutter
un peu.  vous savez que
ce
n'est pas une réponse pour traverser le
processus de deuil
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
étrangère [Musique
] [Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
merci
[Musique] [
Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
en fait  je me souviens de la réalité de
je ne t'ai pas tout dit, ce type demande
combien d'enfants tu as, c'est
intéressant, il va dire
où est ton mari,
j'allais
peut-être croire qui ne me connaît pas, qu'en fait
tu connais les situations  aussi
incroyable que les deux hommes en même temps
Hôpital
je me demande quand ça va s'arrêter
comme je te l'ai dit, chaque combat
te rendra plus fort
le Camino fait partie de la guérison dont tu as besoin
pour être fort tu as été fort dans ta
vie il s'est passé des choses dans  ta
vie et grâce à ça tu es devenu plus fort
oh ouais je pense que je suis fort mais
j'ai juste l'impression que je n'ai pas de
piles Je pense juste que me promener
demain dans un articles divers pour se détendre pas de
bâtons de randonnée pas de sac à dos ça va être
plutôt cool
je  J'ai senti que les ischio-jambiers se sont contractés
hier
et c'est plus une assurance qu'autre
chose. Je l'ai attaché donc je ne peux pas
l'étendre en arrière
et l'étirer trop loin,
mais à la fin de la journée, c'est ce que je me
sens beaucoup mieux après avoir été  malade
pendant une semaine
ouais,
quelques jours vont
mieux, je serai dangereux,
oh, il y a un bon lit, un bon
repas, une
bonne compagnie devrait aller, c'est
ce que nous avons vécu la plupart
du temps,
à part cette nuit à Bates.
Motel
[Musique]
étrangère
regarde le film
peux-tu s'il te plaît attends-
moi,
es-tu avec moi aujourd'hui
J'y suis presque, j'ai fini
mon Kindle Je peux le faire Je peux le faire m'asseoir
un moment désolé ouais
j'aime ça  je ne sais pas quoi pouvoir me
lever
oh c'est un peu embarrassant de
vieillir
et je voulais toujours faire des choses que tu
faisais avant et tu sais que tu ne peux pas et
tu essaies de les faire et ça ne marche pas
et plus tu essaies d'en rire, plus
tu te sens mal à l'intérieur,
parfois c'est difficile d'être positif
alors tu
descends puis tu reviens,
c'est juste que
je veux toujours que ça marche parce que je
voulais travailler
[Musique]
[Musique] à
l'étranger
maintenant que  nous atteignons le
stade spirituel, nous sommes encore dans beaucoup de
montées et de descentes comme vous l'êtes dans la vie mais le
paysage est totalement magnifique [
Musique] des
allées couvertes de petits ruisseaux il y a
beaucoup de beauté et beaucoup de chance de
regarder  au décor et dis qui a mis ça
ici
[Musique]
merci
au bar
[Musique]
tu ne t'es pas arrêté à la douche du bas
qui va dire qu'ils veulent passer 40
jours en balade avec leur beau-père
non  beaucoup de gens
mais j'adore ça, pas de problème du tout,
je pense que c'est juste que nous nous lions très
très bien ensemble, d'accord,
doublez-
vous, obtenez-vous un demi-certificat chacun, nous nous aidons en quelque sorte à
traverser cela
parce que oui, nous avons besoin de l'aide de chacun,
je pense  nous sommes à l'
endroit où, en
février de l'année dernière, ma fille de deux ans
était euh malade, elle avait une pneumonie, c'était
seulement huit mois après la mort de Maddie,
c'est ce que je voulais vous montrer,
nous étions confrontés à la vraie perspective de perdre
un autre enfant et Terry l'a dit  moi l'
histoire que
j'ai eue sur l'ancien formulaire Camino et
j'ai exprimé que
cela n'allait pas dans notre sens d'
organiser la messe à dire dans cette
église
et cela a été dit l'année dernière,
j'y suis allé l'année dernière et je pense que le prêtre,
je pensais juste que tu  Je sais que vous aimeriez peut-être
savoir,
alors ils ont eu du désordre dans ce défi,
vous et vos filles,
très
bien, c'est que nous nous arrêtons là-dedans, ouais,
je vois absolument un trou. J'ai dit aux
bénévoles : vont-ils rénover
l'église qu'elle a dit avoir
et  c'est ce qu'ils voulaient,
je vous laisse aussi, de
parfaits inconnus d'un autre pays
avaient prié pour mes filles dans
cette même église, c'était ouais
indescriptible
[Musique] [
Musique] une
croisière vers Pharaon
a évidemment été
organisée là-bas vers le 11ème siècle, c'est
le  point culminant de tout le Camino,
les gens prennent des pierres pour se souvenir de quelqu'un
ou dans le cadre de la mise de
côté de leurs problèmes, le nombre de personnes
qui sentent qu'ils ont posé une pierre de 20 grammes
et qu'ils se sont débarrassés d'une tonne de
problèmes et ont marché  là, c'est assez
incroyable
[Musique]
en 2002 j'étais séparé,
je portais encore cette bague depuis
plusieurs années mais des pensées ont commencé à
bouillonner sur le fait d'en
arriver peut-être au point de pouvoir
me séparer de ce symbole de
rupture d'unité  ce fil pour que je puisse
continuer à avancer
[Musique]
Je l'ai quitté,
c'est un beau moment triste d'
abandonner autre chose
[Musique]
parce que
ça vient d'être la croisière que j'ai  j'aime ça,
je pense que n'importe qui pourrait essayer de livrer
en fait, mais tu sais, si je meurs avec, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
[Musique] [
Musique]
Paul a toujours dit que tu es né seul,
c'est vrai [Musique
]
et sur cette note
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai ruiné ma virilité, ok, je
m'amuse, je vous
aime, les gars,
voilà, c'est
génial, c'est si lourd,
je vais probablement finir par rater le Camino
et il me manquera juste l'ouverture et
la beauté,
mais pour l'instant, je suis  vraiment très impatient d'y
aller
[Musique]
ça fait 105 kilomètres nous sommes vraiment sur
le tronçon Homewood maintenant
nous y sommes presque je
peux voir les personnages de Santiago
[Musique]
hé 100
excellent
tu as compris
c'est cool
ouais
il n'y a personne autour de nous
nous  J'ai deux Harrows différents ici mais
il n'y en a pas là-bas.
J'aimerais pouvoir répondre à une
question,
peut-être ici, dans cet endroit,
[Musique]
il fait absolument glacial
au cours de la dernière demi-heure, les
températures ont chuté d'au moins quatre
degrés,
il fait vraiment  vraiment froid mais
toujours beau
oh qu'est-ce que je n'aurais pas pour un bon feu de bois
maintenant sérieusement je donnerais mon bras gauche
je viens de voir un flocon
[Musique]
ce n'est pas bon pour les genoux enfin
pas les miens ce matin de toute façon
ils ont besoin de le faire  être de retour dans leur lit
[Musique]
merci
c'est une grosse limace
[Musique]
donc je vais me faire écraser parce que
les gens ne les voient tout simplement pas
[Musique]
j'ai hâte de rentrer à la maison
plus que trois jours après ça
point mental à ce qu'elle a réalisé, ça
se termine et ça ne peut pas être
assez clair, tu sais,
[Musique]
[Musique] étrangère
pour monter là-dedans,
où allons-nous, c'est ce que c'est, nous
n'y retournerons
plus, je suis  Je ne reviens pas, je vais juste
passer cette journée à cause de la
douleur qui s'est manifestée trop tôt,
mais pour le moment, je me dirige vers un café,
malheureusement, nous avons tourné à droite, ici, nous avons
esquivé deux flèches à gauche, et
bien, quand nous sommes sortis de l'auberge, nous
aurions dû tourner à gauche.  nous avons essayé de
le rejoindre ici même si je sais mais à l'origine
ouais ouais
[Musique] c'est
vrai et nous voilà
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] on
dirait que l'Alberta
traverse la ville
[Musique]
c'est très rouge
il n'y a pas d'ongle dessus
[Musique  ]
ok,
je pense que nous devrons peut-être te trouver un
médecin bientôt,
c'est devenu
tellement douloureux
alors
j'ai dû
céder, je ne ris pas parce que je suis heureux, je
ris parce que je ne veux pas
pleurer.  ça n'aide pas de voir tous ces gens
passer
mais ça va être bien d'
entrer avec tout le monde
et je vais le faire avec un spirituel
ou pas [
Musique] [
Musique]
étranger [
[Musique]
génial
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je sais
[Musique] [Musique
] c'est doux [Musique]
sur moi une bière ou est-ce que je vais t'acheter une
bière
[Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
étrangère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique] [Musique]
étrangère [
Musique]
merci
[Musique]
étrangère
ça fait mal
[Musique]